you can see that what I've done here is
I just kind of tidied up what we
informally did earlier on this morning
and just said okay this weird thing here
what is it
okay well when you see that that weird
symbol it's called the integral sign
okay
the integral sign means as the letter
suggests you're adding up a bunch of
things you're taking a sum that's why
it's literally a stretched RS okay
the sum is going to be a bunch of
rectangles and those rectangles have
this height and this width okay this
height and this with it you remember how
we constructed that in the earlier
example with the rocket okay
however the difference between this and
our old friend Sigma notation is that
Sigma notation treats everything in nice
big integer blocks right it's like
there's the one and then the two within
the three whereas the integral notation
actually borrows an idea from calculus
taking the limit as this DX business
goes toward zero
do you remember that when we were doing
first principles right we would say the
limit as now we would say H approaches
zero right to remember that but H what
was H it was the tiny little rod do you
remember that it's the it's the this
rise over run so you could write it like
this right as that approaches here and
what you had up here was X plus that
there's your rise and then on the bottom
you've got your run okay
now this idea from first principles of
differentiation it shouldn't be that
much of a surprise that we borrow it and
we use it inside here as well so if you
want to think about it this way the
integral notation is kind of like Sigma
notation except you divide up your
object into well have a look at this
diagram I cannot have to destroy it
instead of thinking it as nice neat
rectangles right what you have is an
infinite set of infinitesimally thin
rectangles each of which has its own
independent height and each of which has
its own infinitesimally thin width okay
now if you just thought about one of
those such rectangles it would have no
area because infinitesimally thin but if
you added up an infinite number of them
just like when we add up you know one of
these things whoops oh yeah that's right
right when you add up an infinite series
like a geometric progression okay you
actually get something at the end we're
doing something very very similar here
which in fact the main reason why we did
series of sequences before we did this
it's to gear your my adopt for adding up
a whole bunch of different things where
those things tend to Ward really really
small things but they still add up to
something okay so the first important
thing I want to emphasize here which I
didn't talk about this morning because
we've just been over those is how much
you can see the letter X can you see the
pretty real X there it's very important
comes up a lot of times in fact it's so
important I want to highlight it for you
because it both matters and doesn't
matter let me explain that in a second
okay so let's have a look at it I see it
once twice three times four times whoops
five times so the excellent appear many
many times
let me explain firstly the way in which
in some ways it doesn't matter what
those what the x is okay the letter x is
what we call a dummy variable that's a
weird phrase but that's actually a
technical term it's got a dummy variable
okay now I was talking to us about this
is amol because he asked the question
related to it those of you who've ever
played or seen played the game of
football right touch football you know
that kind of thing or rugby league or
whatever you guys know that when someone
gets the ball okay there's nothing
roughly ball shape to you that's okay
whatever someone gets the ball okay and
then they get tackled okay and then what
do they have to do well they have to
take the ball they put it on the ground
and then they pass it to someone
directly behind them okay now that
person is called the dummy half right
now what's their job well once they get
the ball okay so the person behind is
just put it down they pick it up the
immediate thing they do is they get rid
of all they pass her to someone else
right so they don't hold on to it long
term it kind of like a little
placeholder it's like just for a second
they have it and then they quickly get
rid of it and that's what
with this go back to your earlier
examples do you remember the first thing
you would have would have this in it and
then immediately on the next life
all the exes are gone because they've
been replaced by numbers right you
evaluated the definite integral okay so
it's a dummy variable which means I
could just as easily have written for
example a B F of Y dy okay if this is
the same function right if say f of X
was I don't know some completely
randomly selected function okay then F
of Y would be the same thing just with
Y's instead of X's and so when you put
some numbers into this you'll get the
same figure right the results will be
the same so this thing here and this
thing here are identical they will both
eventually equal some number I'm just
going to call it k all right
so the number has nothing to do with X
or Y the number is 8 or 23 or 5 pi okay
and it doesn't care whether it came from
a Y or whether it came from an X okay so
that's the first thing to note it's
called a dummy variable because in a
real sense it doesn't matter when you
are evaluating it you will just get a
number at the end it doesn't matter
where you started but it kind of does
matter because watch what happens now if
I actually do go through in wrong color
and replace all the X's with wise
because you'll notice if you have a look
at my formal definition and if you
haven't written it down do you write it
down watch what happens if I do actually
change it with respect to the whole
definition watch if I go F of Y dy then
I go well that's not next anymore that's
a that's a why that's not x equals a its
y equals a this is not x equals B it's y
equals B when you think about the
integral as an area like this thing here
it actually is something different now
here's another different function I just
drew something to be convenient right if
this is FX then when I do this integral
it's going to be up here now
do you see this look it's against the
y-axis that's over here right it's
between y equals a and y equals B a B so
now I've got a whole different shape
altogether it's an area in a whole
different place does that make sense so
the variable it's sort of matters but it
sort of doesn't depending on how you're
actually using it okay if you're like
I'm in a question I don't know which one
is which then just ask me and I'll help
you okay
now speaking of which is which I want
you to remember that this guy here is
adding up a whole bunch of intensive
liftin rectangles and you end up with
geometrically what do you end up with
you end up with an area don't you okay
so being this is an area you can think
of it in two different ways you can
evaluate it two different ways you can
actually just find the area like look at
the shape it's a it's a square it's a
rectangle it's a semicircle whatever
okay if that's easier then go for it
no calculus required all this means it's
is it's the area so find the area
whatever is the easiest way okay but
sometimes such as the two examples I
have on the board I don't even know what
this shape is gone I don't even know if
this shape has a name let alone what
it's called so you know how that formula
for this the area of a wiggly thing okay
you don't have a formula for it so
therefore you can't just go in the area
as if it were a normal plain figure you
have to treat it as something that you
have to do calculus to so you're gonna
have to find the primitive put those
boxes around and do that so something
like this oops
from A to B okay now I'm gonna push on
this for a second how do you tell which
one you use
just like in calculus when you were
differentiating you trying to find the
nature of a stationary point how did you
choose whether you use the first
derivative or the second derivative you
looked at which one was easier but how
did you know which one was easier if I
gave you a random function I gave you a
random function like this and I said off
you go determine finalisation place to
determine their nature which one would
you use for this one
I hope we would mostly use the second
area here right because differentiating
once gives you 2x plus five
differentiate again just gives you two
different shading it's really easy no
problems whereas if I said for instance
this like ah ah forget that okay I want
differentiate that again the more times
you differentiate it the worse it just
rapidly unravels okay
so that's how you choose so you look at
the function and you make a judgement
well it's the same deal here right you
must look at this function and you have
to make a judgement right is it an easy
shape do you end up with a recognizable
triangle trapezium parallelogram
something like that then then just do
that if it's not then you're gonna have
to like for example in these cases right
you're going to have to go through the
primitive does that make sense